could you imagine that we are all so  powerful that we actually exist beyond  the confines of time and space and even  beyond a body beyond any like linear  physical confines you know so much of  our reality machinery as you say is like  really predicated on this collective  agreement  you know collective asleep Ness you know  that says X Y Z you know confined  limited potential a lot of control and a  lot of fear therein and for me what  feels more true is well actually we're  all you know completely infinite in our  capacity to access any information at  any time we have access to all that all  that ever is all that ever was all that  ever will be and you know another way to  think of the Akashic records is the  known field